five four three two one
lovely
cerium is one of the two elements which
if you strike it will make sparks
so if I bang it in that breaks
so hopefully we can see we should be
able to see if I can get some on the end
of my spatula it should be able to burn
with some sort of green flame
hey there it is
see what this reaction is like it's
burning away other than a hydrogen which
is generating and you can see the orange
sodium flame
I think you got the poets on your camera
the mold would convert the arsenic into
a volatile compound and several people
were killed by the arsenic coming from
their wallpaper
and puts it in a big magnetic field the
electrons could go round and round
around
that's what happens as the balloon
starts to warm up again because the
gases are gaining more energy and they
were occupying more space and becoming
more buoyant so the helium is got back
to the ceiling where it really wants to
be
and so it is said that people get off
the bus when selenium chemists get on
and tellurium is even worse still
so we have reached our destination
hi do you speak English
yes yes continue this road uh-huh it's
not much to see all right look at the
other
left hello
has said finding nothing about her sir
should we make something up
we also need oil to protect the uranium
terms if you really finally divide
uranium turnings that pyro fight between
to burst into flames in the air
so here you can see the lovely blue
liquid oxygen color going into there to
the cot wall particles okay
and there she blows
so we're trying to make literal emphatic
translations of the ethiopian
translation of the element names one of
the girls has just come up with a
fantastic name for magnesium element
number 12 it is 12 so Maggie Johnston
from Brazil so I call it survival
and pulls the Galleon so it's in a nice
proud ball what we then do is we dribble
a small amount of dichromate solution in
which removes the sulfate from the
surface and that has the gallium to go
flat
so we care because we're interested in
the elephant elements Resort starting up
and the elephant the periodic table
elephants
so potassium mint metal is very reactive
one of my colleagues used to work with
it described it as evil
look at him
you